we're waiting to hear whether the
russians will reply to the latest
american offer of torts next week but
the problem we have here is that they
might be crazy
uh if putin was acting rationally he
certainly wouldn't take the huge risk of
an invasion he would take the best offer
he can get through negotiations but
putin is a man who mixes the rational
and the irrational he's very often
driven by emotion and vengeance we saw
that in chechnya we've seen that with
novichow attacks in salisbury we've seen
that in other places and at the moment i
think he's driven by an irrational
belief that the west is trying to steal
ukraine from russia but he's been
humiliated there
that russia is a victim he has a long
narrative of victimhood that nato is
encroaching and that the west wants to
take russia apart
and this is a man who's very isolated he
doesn't talk to many people he has
people around him who don't challenge
him and i think that's the danger and
that's why it's very hard to predict his
actions on the basis of any rationality
well just tell us some more about that
than sir roderick about this sort of
sense of victimhood that you think
president putin will be facing i mean
you obviously were in russia just i mean
how is he viewed by his inner circle is
he viewed as the person who will make
the best decisions does there no sense
of questioning if his decisions are
right
well i remember when i remember sitting
with tony blair when he tried to discuss
church near with putin and whenever you
raised the subjection with putin he
would go off into a 20-minute emotional
rant and there was no way of turning
this into a discussion and when i talked
to putin's staff he said exactly the
same problem arose when they tried to
discuss uh chechnya with putin other
parts of the conversation he'd be
perfectly rational and really quite
sensible um but when the emotion gets
held i mean when he feels that russia is
being victimized and he is i think
convinced himself of that
then you get this sense of vengeance
and he is so often acted in a way that
is very damaging to russia's interests
so when we look at whether storm
vladimir is about to hit ukraine we have
to factor in
uh the element that putin may not be
doing his mass in the same way that we
do the mass
yeah and so then if dealing with an
irrational actor then do you then
support this idea i know that's been
sort of um dismissed now of putting some
kind of force within ukraine to
completely deter him from ever stepping
foot into that territory even the
rational actor sees that there's a huge
army there he's probably unlikely to
invade isn't he
no i think that would be a crazy thing
to do ukraine is not a member of nato
it's not subject to article 5 of the
nato charter
um
and
uh if we put
if nato put forces into ukraine to fight
russia you're getting on the first step
to a really really serious war um and uh
i don't think that's the way to handle
it i think that nato has done completely
the right thing by reinforcing its
position on the eastern flanks in a
purely defensive way but
let us not give russia a further excuse
to think that nato is trying to attack
russia we know it isn't but there is a
perception
in the heads of some people in the
kremlin but nato has got some plot to
encroach on russia um
it would be a certain lose-lose if we
did that
okay sergey line do appreciate your
expertise and analysis thank you for
being with us this morning thank you